start with the basics what exactly is
this impeachment process and how will it
unfold the Constitution gives Congress
the power to remove a president before
their term is up if enough lawmakers
vote to say the president committed
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors it starts with an
investigation by the House Judiciary
Committee hearings are held and a vote
is taken if a majority of the house
agrees to a resolution called articles
of impeachment the president is
technically impeached something that's
happened to two presidents Andrew
Johnson in 1868 and Bill Clinton in 1998
but being impeached doesn't mean the
president is immediately removed from
office think of it as an indictment what
happens next is the trial that takes
place in the Senate presided over by the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court the
house appoints managers to make its case
and the president has a legal team to
make his the Senate then votes and needs
a two-thirds majority to convict and
remove the president from office we'll
get to that later with Senator Blackburn
one of the hundred people on this jury
but just to be clear there are currently
47 Senate Democrats so it would take at
least 20 Republican votes to remove the
president from office okay that's the
official process but what is all this
really about well there is a Maya
Angelou quote the Democrats are fond of
when talking about President Trump when
someone shows you who they are believe
them the first time all right then
and Beachbody by if you're asking what I
vote to teach this president the answer
is yes they've been wanting to impeach
Trump from practically the moment he was
elected on Tuesday afternoon Nancy
Pelosi jumped on the bandwagon with a
statement quoting Benjamin Franklin and
Thomas Paine to try and bring some
constitutional legitimacy but earlier
that day she let slip the real
motivation what's more serious is that
he can't win there you have it the most
serious thing it's stopping Donald Trump
being re-elected it's not about the
Constitution it's about retribution
they hate Trump can't believe he won in
2016 and a worried he'll win again in
2020 they lecture us about democracy in
the rule of law but they're the ones who
want to use non democratic means to get
rid of a democratically elected
president this Ukraine story is just the
latest pretext first it was collusion
than obstruction when none of that
worked they gave up for a few weeks
oh no they thought we might have to try
and beat him in an actual election but
then just in the nick of time
a whistleblower came along and boy were
they excited
here's congresswoman Jackie Speier last
week she's on the impeachment committee
and frankly you know this turned out to
be a gift because it is so clear so
blatant and so corrected a gift so much
for Nancy Pelosi x' BS about how sad
this all is now about that whistleblower
who gave the democrats their gift the
New York Times reported last week that
he's a CIA bureaucrat let me remind you
of another anonymous bureaucrat who made
a splash in the New York Times all about
a year ago we know because they told us
that there's an organized group of
unelected officials actively
plotting against the elected president
they're supposed to serve we also know
that this latest attempt to overturn the
2016 election was put into motion just
as the Democrats were giving up on the
Miller report as the basis for
impeachment and according to an
independent Justice Department memo this
whistle blow is an anti-trump partisan
his defenders say trust him because he
followed the right process but that's
not true he followed the right process
until his claim was rejected then it
leaked to the press read the document he
wrote he comes across as what he is a
pompous arrogant bureaucrat who's
horrified by the idea that a political
outsider could barge into his cozy
ruling elite snooty establishment pearl
clutches say it's outrageous to
disparage this person that would never
have happened under Obama can you
imagine well yes if your name is Edward
Snowden when a whistleblower embarrasses
Obama he's vilified but if he helps them
get trumped he's dead what utter
hypocrites and charlatans these
Washington establishment types are any
journalist who uncritically accepts the
claims of this whistleblower is allowing
their contempt for Trump to destroy
their judgment now what about the
alleged wrongdoing here the most serious
claim is that President Trump withheld
US military aid as a quid pro quo for
Ukraine to investigate Joe Biden the
media has put out what they call a
damming timeline the call with the
Ukrainian president happened on July 25
on August 12 the whistleblower filed
their complaint at the end of August
President Trump
effectively put a hold on military aid
money on September 1st the VP met with
the Ukrainian leader eight days later
House committees started investigating
and by September 12th right after Adam
Schiff was started to started to ask
questions about the complainant the aid
was lifted that claiming that Trump only
released the aid once he knew Congress
was investigating there's just one
problem with that timeline it leaves out
two crucial facts and one crucial step
first fact everyone knows Trump is an
aid skeptic holding up the aid to
Ukraine is totally consistent with his
policy position with what he said
repeatedly to other world leaders to the
NATO secretary-general and to the
president of Ukraine on that now famous
phone call second fact as Ken Vogel of
the New York Times reported Ukraine
didn't even know the aid was being held
up until a month after that call how on
earth can you have a quid pro quo when
one side doesn't even know about the quo
here's how President Trump explained it
you explain why aid to Ukraine was
stopped because I think that other
countries should be paying also why is
the United States the only one paying in
Ukraine I said hold it up let's get
other people to pay and then everybody
called me all please can we pay and now
we have corroboration in the form of
senator rob portman on that date I
called the president because we were
getting to the point where the funds had
to be released and the president was
very clear with me he only raised one
issue and and that issue only and that
was about the Europeans not doing enough
I don't disagree with him on that and
you know we were kind of at the point
where we had to complicate the fun so
they could be effective for Ukraine to
defend itself so we needed to get the
money going but you know I think the
president was interested in using the
funds as leverage to try to get the
Europeans to do more that's what he said
to me wait so here's the crucial step
that's left out of the establishment
timeline on the 11th of September Rob
Portman calls the president later that
day the aid is released it's got nothing
to do with investigating Joe Biden when
supposedly serious and impartial
journalists failed to include those
details because they exonerate the
President on the quid pro quo charge
they are deliberately misleading you The
Wall Street Journal had it right when it
said about the Ukraine call and the
alleged quid pro quo
the conversation was largely routine
diplomacy and even the reference to Joe
Biden was less than promoted by the
press good luck persuading Americans
that this is an impeachable offense
right on to the second claim that the
president invited a foreign guy
to interfere in our elections now let's
not be naive you think president Trump
is the first American leader to bring
domestic political concerns into the
relationship with another country at the
end of their first meeting Barack Obama
leaned over to my ol boss David Cameron
and to coin a phrase like a mob boss
told him which side he should be on in
the 2008 election in 1992 the Bush
campaign asked the British conservatives
for dirt on Bill Clinton those are just
two examples I know about personally
even the New York Times editorial board
while coming out today for impeachment
admits Trump is not alone in this quote
have other presidents conducted foreign
policy with re-election in mind of
course more recently the Democrats
seemed to spend their entire time trying
to get dirt from foreign governments
last year a group of Democrat senators
asked a Ukrainian official for dirt on
Trump in 2016 the Democrats reportedly
tried to get dirt on Trump from the
Ukrainian government asking for Paul
Manafort to be investigated and of
course the big one Hillary Clinton
paying British and Russian government
sources for dirt on Trump now there's no
doubt President Trump talked about
investigating Joe Biden with the
Ukrainian president the Democrats in the
establishment are resting their case on
the words I would like you to do us a
favor and here we come to the central
astonishing brazen dishonesty of the
Democrats and every journalist who
claims there's something here on foreign
interference let's read together the
transcript of the call quote I would
like you to do as a favor though because
our country has been through a lot and
Ukraine knows a lot about it I would
like you to find out what happened with
this whole situation with Ukraine they
say CrowdStrike I guess you have one of
your wealthy people the server they say
Ukraine has it there are things that
went on the whole situation when
President Trump asked for a favor he's
not asking about Biden but allegations
that Ukraine was somehow involved in
twenty sixteen election hacking when he
asked for a favor President Trump was
not asking for future foreign meddling
he was asking about past four
meddling again as The Wall Street
Journal noted quote there is nothing
wrong with asking a foreign head of
state to investigate meddling in US
elections later in the call the
conversation turns to Rudy Giuliani and
allegations of wrongdoing by Joan hunter
Biden President Trump does indeed
encourage the Ukrainian president to
pursue these but guess who brings it up
no not president Trump at president's
events key he's the one that instigates
there back and forth about the Biden
situation by bringing up Giuliani you
can argue that the president might have
been wiser to respond by saying you know
what that's getting into a political
matter and we probably shouldn't talk
about it but the idea that this call and
the so-called whistleblower complaint
about it his evidence that President
Trump abused his office for personal
gain called the world leader to ask him
to get dirt on his opponent medal in our
election and used American military aid
as leverage to make him do it is a joke
a complete joke now we have evidence
that it's a joke the fact that the
Democrats and their media
co-conspirators are already moving away
from it as the basis for impeachment
remember how they dropped collusion and
switched to obstruction it's happening
again
they know there's no case on the quid
pro quo or the foreign interference so
guess what now it's cover up the
anti-trump bureaucrat activists re
whistleblower revealed that White House
officials put the Ukraine transcript in
a computer system designed for national
security secrets not run-of-the-mill
diplomatic calls like sheep they recite
the cliche it's the cover-up that gets
you not the crime are they serious first
as we've shown you there was no crime
second don't they remember that
shockingly some of president Trump's
early phone calls with world leaders
were leaked why should anyone be
surprised if the president's calls are
made extra secure after that but finally
the most obvious idiocy of the coverup
claim the White House published the damn
call proactively before any subpoena or
legal process they voluntarily published
the whole thing some cover up it's
incredible to me that any serious person
could take any of this seriously and yet
we see
every Democrat spouting this obvious
nonsense almost every news anchor doing
it we even hear that if it was a secret
ballot at least 30 Republican senators
would vote to convict President Trump
and remove him from office unbelievably
in a presidential election year there's
only one explanation class loyalty
ruling class loyalty for 50 years a
ruling class of Republicans and
Democrats permanent officials in the
government bureaucracy big business
bosses with their donations and
lobbyists have run the world in their
interests their ideology was based on
globalism with two key components free
trade and open borders globalism made
the ruling class richer and working
Americans poorer if you're operating on
a global not just a national scale you
can get much bigger and make much more
money if you open your borders you can
import as many new workers as you want
and pay all the rest of them less so
your profit margins are higher in 2016
America elected a president who stood
against all that and has exactly as he
promised started to turn it around this
is why they're defending Joe Biden so
ferociously Biden is the absolute
epitome of the corrupt ruling class as I
said on Twitter last week the ruling
class act all outraged about foreign
interference in our democracy through
election meddling that's just not right
they scream no the right way to do it is
to cut out the middleman don't waste
time on stupid elections just have the
foreign countries medal directly in our
government foreign governments interfere
in our democracy every day in Washington
through all the swampy techniques we've
shown you over the years
hiring lawyers and lobbyists funding
think tanks and putting former
government officials and current
officials relatives directly on their
payroll what total disgusting hypocrites
they are Nancy Pelosi took money from
lobbyists representing shady companies
in Ukraine Chuck Schumer took money from
lobbyists for the Saudi Arabian and
Mexican government's President Obama's
former head of cybersecurity now works
for huawei an arm of the Chinese
government president transformer defense
secretary James Madison now works for
the swampy Cohen
which boasts about shipping American
defense jobs overseas and selling
American manufacturing firms to foreign
countries and of course Joe Biden forget
about the Ukraine corruption that's
nothing he took over a billion dollars
in bribes from the Chinese government
America's number one adversary in the
form of payments to Biden family
businesses in exchange for policy favors
hashtag Joe China so spare us the
sanctimonious bleating about foreign
interference Biden Pelosi Schumer the
whole rotten corrupt crew you've been
selling America to the highest foreign
bidder for donkey's years and yes for
personal gain this is globalism in
action this is what America rejected in
2016 and the ruling class just can't
stand it there's one more aspect to this
on top of the economic devastation that
globalism brought to working Americans
and so many Heartland communities
there's the cultural condescension
especially on the left with their
intolerance and hate and woke mania the
ruling class looked down their noses at
the very people who are the victims of
their ideas they sneer at their faith
even their food the establishments Trump
hatred is not policy based it's
class-based they think he's vulgar they
mock him because he likes McDonald's the
policy achievements most notably that
turnarounds on jobs and especially China
they mean nothing to them they just hate
this peasants revolt that's why so many
journalists are going along with this
impeachment farce they're part of the
ruling class - they're desperate to fit
in at Washington dinner parties they
crave approval on media Twitter the
challenge to globalism the class
prejudice that's what the Trump
impeachment is about it is class war we
didn't start it the ruling class did but
we sure as hell are going to fight to
the end for the populist revolution